more people move to las vegas and home
prices surge it's making it tough to
purchase a home
now clark county is asking for proposals
to build an affordable housing
development
near cactus and buffalo that's in the
southwest part of the valley
kate houston breaks down who qualifies
and also reaction about the project
this bear plot of land will soon hold
100 homes local leaders tell me this is
crucial
given the severe shortage of affordable
housing in southern nevada
with low supply and high demand it's not
easy to buy a home
people that were making 60 70 000 you
could get away with it back then
80s and 90s you can't get away with that
nowadays there's not enough houses
for people brodie bender recently
relocated to mountain's edge
to build new infrastructure that's going
to help
supply housing and places for people to
live is
fantastic southern nevada is short 60 to
70
thousand affordable housing units this
development would sell homes or condos
to lower income families
to give families in particular a
different look
a different opportunity than most of the
apartments that we have right now
clark county commissioner justin jones
represents this area
and is looking for developers if
successful the county will sell the land
to the developer at a discount they're
already building this type of product
it's just that the land values are so
high
that they can't really put something on
the market for less than three hundred
thousand dollars
while many are supportive of the project
there are some concerns
you don't want to lose the value in your
home but yet same time
who doesn't want to have more affordable
housing the county is taking proposals
until june 24th
kate houston 8 news now